[Music]
um
we had an incident earlier where we
called um we have um one of the family
members here is having a bit of a
psychotic break there were a couple of
um offices here earlier and they um
weren't able to find him he was upstairs
and he's here now and he's throwing some
stuff right now so if we could get a
dispatch here that would be helpful um i
don't know the names of the officers who
were here before
but i can get those okay
hold on one second
isn't coming up as an address okay i
might have the number wrong give me one
second what's the number
no the
excuse me you're fine
so
is this a single-family home
okay and what is your name
uh my name is
um you probably got a call earlier from
uh
or a
gotcha okay and uh what is your phone
number
gotcha okay and is he inside the home
right now
he is inside the home right now he did
throw some things and
shatter them we are outside the home
currently
are you related to this person
i am not i am dating her twin brother uh
twin sister excuse me
hold on one second for me don't
disconnect i'm gonna get a call started
on this um
i had to just make sure i found the
previous event from this call as well
he's just in the home doing that i
haven't heard any crashes since we have
left so he might have calmed down but he
you know is a little frazzled and
mentally unstable right now when someone
is inside the house
gotcha all right um well i have the call
started right now so um hold on one
second my apologies
now you're fine
uh do you know his name
his name yes his name is
uh
i'm sorry
yes correct you mentioned what we called
earlier yes i did okay let me know if
you want my dad's number yeah if you
want um we have the father's number the
mother's number as well i believe the
mother's number was given to the former
cops and who were here
gotcha
and uh do you know his date of birth
yeah
gotcha okay
and the last thing was
yeah
gotcha and i'm gonna be asking for a
description though just in case he
leaves uh is he white black asian
hispanic
he's white about five foot six um short
but it's got hair
um
or just a t-shirt yeah
black
yeah we're standing in the front yard
right now
um and he hasn't come out through the
front door since we have been here okay
uh and uh does he have any weapons in
the home
no no no
no weapons of any kind inside the house
is he having or is he under the
influence of drugs or alcohol
no he is not okay
gotcha
okay and does he have a history of uh
mental illness
he's he's struggled with mental health
but he's never had a breakdown like this
like he has a therapist and um
but he's never
ever had like a breakdown he's always
just you know had some anxiety
depression like we've been working on
but
this has never ever happened before is
he diagnosed with anything specific
aside from anxiety or depression
no no official diagnosis gotcha
okay uh has anyone in the home uh or
unseen had covert or had any symptoms in
the last 14 days
no no okay and has anyone been in
isolation or quarantined for covert
exposure
no
all right uh if anything changes just
call second let us know but we have them
on the way to you right now
okay excellent do you have an eta uh no
i don't but they're already on their way
so they should be there
okay all right thank you very much
but she says she believes he's a danger
to himself he keeps breaking things
prior um
he was doing the same thing breaking
things and we tried to come and find him
but he was gone and neighbor was here
and
yeah are you friends
we just got in from new york we came to
the house i came in and just said hey
it's me your sister and he was at the
top of the stairs
and then he was just saying oh do you
know is muna there i have no idea who
he's talking about and
i said i don't know like you want to
stay there i stay here what helps and
then he just we have pictures by the
stairwell and he turned picking them up
and throwing them over the stairwell and
then said call 9-1-1 and my boyfriend
and i got out what is here
good night
yeah okay we i
i just i don't know if
we have to talk with him if we're not
able to and just
yeah it's kind of hard for us to act on
that yeah so yeah so we don't know his
history could you
how old is he 26. okay yeah could you ex
a note i'm not trying to the meaning or
anything i'm not but could you explain
to us in your own words based on you
knowing he's a brother
um why do you think he is a
danger he's or he's unable to take care
of himself or something like that yeah
you know his history and stuff like that
yeah he's um
he's had had um issues in the past yes
so he's trans male and came out several
years ago and then he's been seeing a
therapist ever since
and has been living with family members
just to help him feel okay come to his
identity and
um
he hadn't had any like
dissociations or hallucinations before
or anything leading us to believe he was
detached from reality
um his therapist had reported some like
oh slight concerning thoughts but
nothing dangered himself for others
and then he was seeming to do better my
my parents were with him they thought he
was doing great they went out of town
and then he found out someone very very
close to him like a previous girlfriend
that he really thought was like the one
um died and now he has
become like hallucinating i was on the
phone with him when i was on the train
back and he was saying there are people
out to get me i'm scared i'm i'm
terrified like you need to call 9-1-1
there's i don't know what to tell you
there's people like controlling my
thoughts
just like kind of schizophrenic type
episodes
and i had a friend come over sharin who
was close by just to see because he said
that would be okay
and um
when she came by just to be with him he
started shouting at her and breaking
things so that since the first 9-1-1
call was because
we've never experienced that behavior
before he'd never been violent or
explosive like that okay
um
what is he diagnosed with
don't have an official diagnosis we
think so maybe somewhat dissociative
identity but like he's never had like an
official diagnosis
so one thing is um
you know
we're not like we'll help as much as we
can but we're kind of like over the last
not the last before but we're like if
it's gotten to the point where he's
going to harm himself immediately
um
so and one thing is if we
what we what we can do is we can
take them into cuss and get them
um
evaluated legal like criminal yeah yeah
and then uh we get them evaluated and
it's up to the clinician if they want to
keep it just be aware that's like kind
of a bridge you can't cross back because
some people don't like the police or no
and we have and we have policies where
you know we take someone in custody we
have to search them cuff them
put them in the cruiser yeah um
do you know if he'll talk to someone
voluntarily
i think since he's really not seems
attached to reality right now like he
might talk but it might not make sense
okay i mean that's if he talks to them
and they the clinician determines that
based on their experience that hey i
don't think they can take care of
themselves then there's something else
then they can commit him and stuff
we just have to have like
harm self for others
did he cut injure himself
maybe in the process but he also when he
was in there he said
um does he eat is he drinking i haven't
really been eating or drinking my
parents checked because he has uses
their credit card he hasn't gotten any
food since they lasted like over a week
that's my boyfriend okay um
so he hasn't been eating he hasn't been
sleeping apparently
um
and
yeah and he when he was in there and
starting to smash picture frames he said
call 9-1-1
yeah
i don't know i know it's like a last
resort but no but it's we have to be
able to like for us to take him to a
clinic it has to be has to be pretty bad
like has to be the point where we have
to get involved like yeah
and i understand i understand yeah yeah
you have to pursue a route where you go
to a mastery and testify that he's a
danger himself because based on what
you're saying it may be hard for us to
get that from what he's saying but we'll
cross that bridge and we'll try and make
contact i'll talk with him and okay him
or her what is he yeah it's him yeah
okay well i'll talk with him and um
i'll see if he even just wants to go
voluntarily okay because i think if they
think they have an issue and they want
to help themselves that's probably the
best issue rather than that's four steps
okay that gives me a little bit of hope
where is he
he went upstairs so you see that back
window up there so is that oh my god is
it he just keeps going
through the front yeah so you can go
through the front and then just go up
the stairwell into your left
yeah mom gave us permission earlier
okay
put it down put it down put it down
put it down put it down we don't
it it down please aaron you're all right
can put
320 off hold the channel please
but it's okay are my parents here you're
not in trouble okay you asked the call
for us remember um
[Music]
i got it